poderío militar es lo que exhibe rusia
en una parada naval en san petersburgo
por el aniversario número 325 de su
armada por caso de ratones el desfile
naval muestra el estado de nuestra flota
y armada y en qué condiciones se
encuentran muestra también nuestro poder
unos que probablemente no tienen ningún
otro país
a parte de los civiles que asistieron
participaron cerca de 4.000 militares
desfilaron más de medio centenar de
navíos entre ellos el submarino nuclear
príncipe vladimir 48 aviones y
helicópteros y a pesar de mostrar su
artillería la marina de guerra de rusia
aseguró que recibirá más de 180 buques y
embarcaciones nuevos hasta 2027
además los misiles de crucero
hipersónicos capaces de volar hasta 9
veces más rápido que la velocidad del
sonido están en su fase final de los
ensayos motores y la armada rusa tiene
hoy todo lo necesario para garantizar la
defensa de la patria y nuestros
intereses nacionales somos capaces de
detectar cualquier blanco enemigo bajo
el agua en la superficie marítima o en
el aire y si es necesario acertarle un
golpe irreversible y el próximo ver este
desfile se de en un momento de tensión
entre rusia y algunos países de la
comunidad internacional entre ellos
figuran estados unidos ucrania y el
reino unido- hace unas semanas hubo un
incidente entre moscú y londres por un
buque británico que navegó en aguas
usas según el ministerio de defensa de
este país